we saw this story I thought it was a
great story and then I found out the
story behind the story and it became
even better the Pirates relievers Steven
brawled he sang the national anthem last
night let me give you a taste of that
then we'll bring in Steven and he'll
tell you how this came about that he was
gonna be at home plate to sing the
star-spangled banner once he got there
then I I knew he was he was in the clear
because there's there's a couple spots
in the anthem and singers will tell you
that where you got to get there and
that's when I think Steven was he threw
a fastball right there and he's kind
enough to join us Steven how are you
today what what are the reviews that you
got from your anthem listening little
high two waiters is that the first time
you've heard out back no I I listen to
it like afterwards home and it was it's
interesting hearing it you know I'm sure
you guys understand but it's weird
hearing it again and me knowing myself
and knowing when I was singing and I was
like that I was kind of a little weird
but you know but ya know it was it was
very once you go and the Rockets red
glare like that that can be death though
like you almost had were you thinking
subconsciously I call boy here it comes
and I got to get to a certain point
absolutely yeah I think that's probably
actually the most underrated part of the
anthem because everybody thinks about
like the free you know
but the Rockets red glare sits right up
there so I I was I was a little worried
I I knew it was coming up so you know it
worked out okay your major league debut
compared to singing the anthem last
night or yesterday the difference in
nerves
ah amazing debut major debut you know
this is I'll tell you life is I made my
major debut in st. Louis in 2016 on July
5th
they're like 45,000 people there and I
could not feel my body for like the
first you know six pitches I could have
thrown the ball like into our dugout and
I wouldn't have been surprised because I
had no idea where was going so the last
thing I was a little less nerve-wracking
not too much but definitely a little bit
less I give the audience the story
behind singing the anti know you've done
at the minor leagues but singing in the
major leagues how did this come about
you know last year a little bit I talked
to the Pirates just kind of initiated a
conversation like you know this is
something I would actually like to do if
you guys would be open to it and in
Clint Hurdle but you know he was he was
all about it he was like oh absolutely
we should get you up there and and then
this offseason and spring training we
continued the conversation and then it
came to a point where they were like so
are you like serious so you actually you
actually want to do this and I said yeah
so we you know scheduled a date and
everything and then you know it actually
happened you know for the last two weeks
have been a little bit like yeah yeah
you know I don't screw it up all of my
very very supportive teammates were all
you know hey don't screw up the words
you know that would be embarrassing
right oh if your voice back so that
would be tough wouldn't it yeah we had a
lot of fun with it but it was it was
cool what's your go-to karaoke song euni
wonder usually go from if I'm going a
little bit more exciting I like nine
steel delivers or I'll go superstition
or verbal Jana a woman yeah but then I'm
feeling I'm trying to make the ladies
you know trying to impress somebody then
I'll go my Sharia more because that's
just a great so it's this little flow we
wear
I love Stevie Wonder but not many people
want to go where Stevie Wonder's gone oh
yeah it's so much fun what's the point
of doing it if you're not going to go
all out you know beautiful they're not
carry out user voice can crack a new
tears because you're singing that 12
people in a bar so fun
how are the pirates doing this year
we're doing pretty good you know we had
a really really really good start
super hot out of the gate and then we
were you know really bad for a while
there and we're evening things out but I
think that you know our team were very
we're super young really I especially
our pitching staff and and you know
we're going through some growing pains
and stuff but it's it's super fun we're
all really close and I think that what
was what's good about our season is that
since we did so well at the beginning
going through a really tough stretch
like we did we're still you know we're
still afloat we're only a you know six
seven games back first place and you
know we have a tough division obviously
so it's it's a good place to be I think
right now he's Steven Broughton he's
sang the star-spangled banner the
Pirates left-hander joining us Dan
Patrick show all right we have signed
sealed delivered or my cherrier or more
so which one do you you want to hear my
cereal or for sure I'll let you sing
along with it let's see a little karaoke
here right so here's Stevie the great
Stevie Wonder and the good Steven
brought hey nice okay here we go
and in three two one
here we go
you know what Steven what you just sing
it
Lala do I have to sing more yeah yeah
yeah just just give me a heart give me a
corn uh yeah in a cafe or sometimes on a
crowded street Oh
near you but you never notice me my
[Music]
where are you right now
I'm sitting in my house okay so you're
not like an apartment building where
somebody's gonna say Stephen stop it the
construction workers that are working on
the house next to mine I think they've
heard me sing a little bit so I think
they're used to at this point
hey it's great happy to have you on and
hope do you get a chance to do it again
and good luck this season Thank You
Stephen thank you I appreciate that
Stephen roll he's sang the national
anthem last night for the Pirates for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]